babies that could have a chance at life
were murdered a person is a person no
matter how small a woman's body is not
up for political debate after 50 years
roe vs wade was overturned in the u.s
the landmark case that gave women the
constitutional right to an abortion
[Music]
there have been mixed reactions from law
making mps here they think that
uh that women have an absolute right of
bodily autonomy
in this matter whereas i think in the
case in the case of abortion that right
is qualified by the fact that another
body is involved this is a proper topic
for political debate and now people are
wondering if something similar to roe
versus wade could happen here in the uk
so we're on our way to meet a young
woman called sam she terminated two
pregnancies when she was in her early
twenties and since then she's been
campaigning to end the stigma around
abortion i'm very very pro-choice
pro-abortion actually if i'm going to be
specific i may as well put that title on
it
and
i think people take for granted that
they think it's easily accessible and
it's a human right and it's a lot more
fragile than people think how protected
and how safe do you think
the
right women's right to abortion is in
this country it could be much safer it
could be much safer it's not enshrined
in law it's enshrining criminal law we
don't have the human right to abortion
at any time in any case at all it still
has to be signed off by two doctors you
still have to prove that it's medically
needed and do you think progress has
been made
in this country
some progress but i don't think we've
pushed hard enough for it to be removed
from criminal law it doesn't make sense
that we're still being governed by laws
from
the past
we are a very different country to
america and in reality it's unlikely
we'd ever go the same way but despite
the fact that over 200 000 abortions
were performed here in 2021 technically
women in england and wales can still be
prosecuted for terminating a pregnancy
did you know that in this country
abortion is actually illegal but only in
certain circumstances it isn't
no i actually didn't know that um that's
really that's really shocking what do
you mean but i didn't know two doctors
to prove that it would
badly damage your mental or physical
health i think a lot of people didn't
know that no i don't think i did no you
might wonder how that works well the
1861 offenses against the person act
which harks back to the victorian era
criminalized abortions a hundred years
later the abortion act in
1967 legalized abortions with an
authorized provider but the deliberate
ending of a pregnancy wasn't legalized
the law is framed in a way that means
abortion is not a right it gives an
exemption from prosecution in certain
circumstances when two doctors agree it
would be risky for the mental or
physical health of a woman the rules in
northern ireland have traditionally been
much stricter but a campaign spearheaded
by the labour mp stella creasy led to
abortion being decriminalized in
northern ireland now across party
amendments being tabled to make abortion
a fundamental right across the uk and
while some mps have condemned the choice
to reverse roe versus wade clearly it
has massive impacts on people's uh
thinking around the world it's a very
important decision i've got to tell you
i think it's a big step backwards others
supported the decision and its
implications
indeed would the minister not agree that
giving legal protection to the unborn is
arguably a clear recognition of the
unborn life and america have done just
that and i welcome the bold and
religious decision
here in the uk laws on abortion are
decided not in the courts but by elected
mps that means enshrining abortion as a
human right by passing a cross-party
amendment won't be simple mps from all
sides of the house would get a vote but
some politicians like dominic rabb warn
that an amendment to enshrine the right
to abortion could lead to other issues
courts could potentially take on cases
that seek to redefine challenge or limit
a woman's right to abortion in the same
way the u.s supreme court did when it
overturned roe versus wade
will he accept the cross-party amendment
to his forthcoming bill of rights which
enshrines a woman's right to choose in
law
the position as she knows is settled in
uk law in relation to abortion it's
decided by honourable members
across this house it's an issue of
conscience i don't think there is a
strong case for change what i wouldn't
want to do uh is find ourselves with a
greater respect in the u.s position
where this is being litigated through
the courts rather than settled as it is
now settled uh by honorable members in
this house every single time it comes to
giving women equal control over their
bodies that men have people find
objections it's plain and simple we
don't have equality in this country
until men and women have equal right to
choose what happens to their bodies and
for women this is a particular right
that is a human right and it needs to be
upheld right now there are people being
put on trial for having abortions in
this country terrible horrific stories
of young women who've had miscarriages
being accused of committing a murder
because it's based on law from the 1800s
stella cruci's right in fact two british
women are facing prison for having an
abortion including one who obtained the
pills from an authorised provider the
alleged crime falls under the offences
against the person act it carries a
maximum sentence of life in prison but
there are those who disagree i spoke to
a pro-life doctor about his concerns so
most people in the uk think that
abortion should be generally available
and legal but as i suggested earlier
most people also think that the current
law is too radical allowing abortion for
any reason up until six months and
allowing abortion up until birth
for if the child has a disability most
people are
shocked when they actually hear what the
law actually says
and of course if abortion were enshrined
as a bill
as a right a basic human rights it's
likely that that would be even more
radical we would see abortion up until
birth for any reason a minority of
people think abortion law should change
and be made stricter sema not her real
name changed her mind about having a
termination because of campaigners
outside a clinic sema now has an
eight-year-old son and thinks access to
abortions is too easy she believes women
should be given more options and more
support and abortion should be the last
resort
it was unplanned pregnancy
but
i always wanted a second child as well
but our circumstances were
very bad at that time it's very easy
here
so when you go and ask them that they
straight away give you
this mary stops number and then they
book your appointment they they don't
they are not interested in you whatever
i think it's
like a business
it should be stricter people should
consider what they're doing
you know some of the sort of um
catastrophizing might be might be
unwarranted in a sense i mean i don't
think there's any realistic chance of um
of anywhere in the uk banning abortion
completely or anything like that anytime
soon um so i don't think we're really
having that conversation the balance
between the rights of an unborn child
and a woman's right to choose has always
ignited strong feelings on both sides of
the debate britain and america though
are very different countries and it
would take a lot in practice for things
to change here ali fortescue sky news